esta mañana cerca de 200 manifestantes
bloquearon una parte de la autopista
periférica norte de París es el acceso
principal a la capital desde varias
regiones del Oeste este y Norte en pie
aún la huelga de recolectores de basura
en su onceno día con cerca de nueve mil
toneladas de desechos acumulados
solamente aquí en la capital esto obligó
al Ministerio del interior a
requisicionar agentes de limpieza es
decir forzarlos a que hagan su trabajo
también esta mañana un grupo de
estudiantes bloqueó la sede en lille de
la Universidad sianspo de dónde es
graduado Por cierto el presidente macron
los sindicalistas de la refinería de
total Energy en normandía anunciaron que
esa planta será detenida por completo
desde el fin de semana Esas son las
acciones de esta mañana pero se esperan
más a medida que avance la jornada Y
todavía se contabilizan los daños de las
degradaciones de las protestas de anoche
cerca de 300 detenidos ya lo mencionabas
la mayoría de ellos aquí en París en
manifestación que reportamos desde el
lugar de los hechos en la Plaza de la
Concordia anoche pero también en una
ciudad a poco más de 300 kilómetros
hacia el oeste de aquí se vivió una
noche extremadamente violenta 26
incendios extinguidos indigón al sureste
de la capital hubo ataques a los agentes
del orden y quema de maniquíes con el
rostro impreso de maco Elizabeth dono y
del ministro del trabajo los cuerpos
republicanos de seguridad también
utilizaron gases lacrimógenos en amián y
renov por por la degradación en las de
la seguridad en esas urbes es decir una
reacción inmediata espontánea de los
franceses Y lamentablemente con
violencia son rasgos en común con el
movimiento de los chalecos amarillos que
sí obligó al gobierno a dar marcha atrás
a medidas que afectaban sobre todo a
trabajadores de regiones suburbanas o
Rurales y ese rechazo no es solo en las
calles Luis Miguel porque opositores
como Marín le pen anunciaron una moción
de censura contra el gobierno
especialmente contra majó Ivonne la
Francia insumisa dijo que apoyará la
medida que se sabe
Bueno hasta el momento hay dos mociones
de censura listas para ser presentadas
esa de reagrupación nacional y dentro de
un par de horas podrían ser votadas las
dos o sea van a ser anunciadas dentro de
un par de horas presentadas Perdón
dentro de un par de horas y votadas a
inicios de la semana que viene todo
parece indicar que sería la propuesta
por el grupo liot diputados
independientes y de ultramar la que será
aceptada por la asamblea nacional para
llevar a debate y posterior votación
porque cuenta con mayor número
designatarios entre ellos los miembros
del grupo de izquierdas luego de que
Francia en su misa retirara la suya para
facilitar el proceso para que esa moción
de censura sea aprobada se necesita al
menos
287 votos esto es solo posible si al
menos la mitad de los diputados del
partido de derecha los republicanos
aprueba la iniciativa hay que hacer
cuentas pero Hablamos de una treintena
de votos ese escenario improbable porque
el líder de ese grupo político anunció
ayer mismo que no apoyarán ninguna
maniobra de ese tipo porque sería
agregar más caos a la crisis en que se
encuentra el país improbable No
significa imposible de hecho ese mismo
líder fue incapaz de lograr un acuerdo
para votar la ley de reforma de
pensiones Y esa división en el su
partido pudiera también manifestarse la
semana próxima